bonjour vous regardez et maintenant
l'émission qui revient avec plaisir et
avec vous sur l'actualité politique de
la semaine vous connaissez le principe
par cœur hashtag et maintenant si vous
souhaitez réagir sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui l'élite de l'analyse
l'aristocratie de la formule choc la
hauteur de vue conjuguée un sourire et
quel sourire aujourd'hui Fabrice
d'Almeida bonjour bonjour historien
vice-président de l'université Panthéon
à Salles je renvoie à votre dernier
livre l'histoire mondiale des riches
c'est publié chez plomb à côté de vous
Bérengère bon ça va ça va très bien
journaliste à France Info vous publiez
Elisabeth band la secrète une biographie
de la première ministre c'est-à-dire aux
éditions de l'archipel merci d'être avec
nous Nicolas bavrez bonjour économiste
éditorialiste vous avez signé démocratie
contre empire autoritaire c'est à
retrouver aux éditions de l'Observatoire
et azélise le corbeau c'est une première
pour vous ravi de vous accueillir vous
êtes journaliste au Figaro dans cette
émission on se demandera si le père Noël
existe et s'il Emmanuel Macron on
partira en Ukraine voir si Poutine est
en train de nous mener une guerre de
civilisation on verra s'il existe une
cancelle culture de droite et si l'État
a lâché les maires de nos communes mais
la violence merci président Larcher
retour sur cette scène un peu
surréaliste cette semaine sur les
Champs-Élysées Emmanuel Macron commémore
la capitulation nazie du 8 mai mais il
le fait seul sans public la foule est
tenue à distance par la police pour
éviter les casseroles et les
manifestations hostiles alors faut-il en
déduire que l'exécutif a peur du peuple
la question a été posée à une ministre
cette semaine
moi j'ai fait découvrir ma rations à
Lens on a été aux deux différents
monuments aux morts on est restés
longuement sur la place et bien entendu
il y a pas eu de progrès parce que c'est
très important et c'est pour ça que
comme tous les autres ministres je n'ai
pas peur du peuple et le président non
plus et vous savez que le président est
l'un des rares présidents à être sortis
dans des moments de tension sociale le
gouvernement a-t-il peur du peuple une
question simple deux positions très
tranchées sur ce plateau d'un côté
Fabrice de l'autre Nicolas vous avez 45
secondes chacun c'est un duel les amis
Nicolas vous allez vous dire pourquoi
selon vous oui le gouvernement a
clairement peur du peuple c'est vrai que
les images qu'on a vu sont sans
précédent le fait que les Français
soient tenus à distance de la
célébration du du 8 mai c'est quand même
quelque chose de de tout à fait oui de
tout à fait inédit et quand on regarde
la différence avec le couronnement de de
Charles III c'est spectaculaire on a
d'un côté un peuple anglais qui était
rassemblé autour du souverain avec une
très belle cérémonie d'ailleurs et avec
des opposants qui avaient toutes leurs
places puisque les opposants à la
royauté ont aussi pu s'exprimer et de
l'autre on a cette énorme vide et je
crois que ce vide est très représentatif
de l'isolement aujourd'hui d'Emmanuel
Macron dans notre pays comme sur la
scène internationale vous avez respecté
votre temps et vous restez deux secondes
avant que je voulais regarderai tout à
l'heure Fabrice pour vous vous êtes pas
d'accord clairement le gouvernement n'a
pas peur du peuple expliquez-nous
pourquoi vous avez 45 secondes alors je
crois pas que le gouvernement ait peur
du peuple et je crois pas que ce soit de
bonnes illustrations pour en parler
parce qu'il se trouve que précisément il
y a des précédents François Hollande à
la fin de son quinquennat le 8 mai il y
a pas grand monde le 11 novembre il y a
pas grand monde c'est concentré
simplement autour de la place de
l'Étoile pour faire les fameuses
poignées de main de fin de cérémonie
ensuite on sait très bien que quand tu
es président se déplacent il y a toute
une ingénierie en fait pour faire venir
la foule pour faire venir les
associations et qu'évidemment on
retrouve la même ingénierie par contre
ce que je pense c'est qu'effectivement
le gouvernement a peur de la radicalité
c'est à dire en fait de petits
groupuscules particulièrement haineux
particulièrement armé qui régulièrement
font des intrusions et il se trouve que
cette semaine on a vu à partir d'un
maire les violences que subissent les
élus et je pense qu'à l'échelle du
gouvernement il y a besoin de cette
sécurité aussi merci Fabrice Azilis vous
allez nous trancher ça qu'est-ce que
vous inspire les images qu'on vient de
voir alors c'est marrant parce que vous
vous parliez de François Hollande moi
quand je vois ces images je pense à la
phrase d'Emmanuel Macron pendant sa
campagne en 2017 quand il avait dit à
son équipe et à ses agents de sécurité
il faut pas que j'ai peur d'aller dans
la foule parce que sinon je vais finir
comme François Hollande et là on a vu
que progressivement puisse six dernières
années le président s'est coupé du
peuple alors je sais pas très bien ce
qu'on appelle le peuple mais en tout cas
n'est pas descendu dans l'arène
politique et cela a commencé après les
gilets jaunes où là il est allé et
ensuite progressivement avec la crise
sanitaire notamment le recours au
Conseil de défense puis dans la dernière
campagne où il laissait un peu mouillé
on voit que cette fracture se fait petit
à petit et là encore une fois ces images
elles me semblent très très violentes
parce qu'on a l'impression que le
président ne communique pas avec ses
concitoyens le président ou la première
ministre est-ce qu'il y a une peut-être
une défiance méfiance générale au sein
du gouvernement aujourd'hui vis-à-vis
des Français il me semble que oui il me
semble que la confiance c'est quelque
chose qui doit être réciproque en fait
et on parle souvent de du fait de la
désaffection du de l'opinion de de
l'abstention évidemment qui était d'une
vraie défiance vis-à-vis des politiques
mais en réalité le moi le gouvernement
d'exécutif me donne l'impression de ne
plus avoir confiance non plus dans le
peuple il ne enfin il ne veut pas de
référendum il ne veut pas il a peur
alors peut-être pas du peuple c'est la
formulation est peut-être pas j'aurais
choisi mais s'exprime tout simplement et
donc ça donne des interdictions de
rassemblement les les les ça donne une
tentative de casserole pour s'exprimer
quand même et même les casseroles sont
interdites
on arrive quand même à
des déplacements du président où il
vient par surprise tous les confrères
journalistes qui couvrent ces on est
même compliqué d'ailleurs qui couvrent
les les déplacements sont prévenus
atterrissent et au dernier moment il dit
non finalement on part par là même les
préfets sont prévenus au dernier moment
enfin et qu'est-ce que ça nous dit de
l'état du pays aussi ces arrêts
anti-castrophes voulaient rappeler
arrêtez anticipé des manifestations sont
interdites qu'est-ce que ça nous dit de
l'état du pays
c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il a pas
peur du peuple je pense qu'il a peur des
petits groupes qui sont assez comment
dirais-je enquister dans leur
détestation de la présidence voire du
gouvernement vous voyez bien le résultat
Fabrice pour les commémorations personne
sur les Champs-Élysées mais c'est pas la
même chose c'est pas la même chose parce
que là où j'aurais quand même je sais
pas tout à fait d'accord avec tout ce
que dit Bérengère c'est que Bérengère
fait comme si il ne voulait pas qu'il y
ait du tout d'expression populaire il y
en a plein d'expressions populaires et
il y a énormément de manifestations
autorisées il y a
la censure est très très très restreinte
donc voilà même sur le cas d'un livre
par 11 ans même sur le cannelli
justement même sur le cas d'un livre le
livre n'est pas retiré donc attendez
parce que d'abord la justice donc quand
il y a avant de dire avant de dire
qu'ils ont peur du peuple qui sont quand
même sauf qu'il y a une image de
manœuvre il y a quand même
l'interdiction il y a une rassemblement
revendicatif certains arrêtés ont été
pris dans ce sens-là Nicolas et puis
surtout le parce que je le maintiens
l'idée de faire le vide sur les
Champs-Élysées qu'on empêche des
ça ça c'est vraiment le fait que
certains présidents n'est pas réussi à
avoir beaucoup d'audience lors du 11
novembre etc oui c'est arrivé mais le
fait qu'on interdise à tout citoyen
d'assister de venir sur les
Champs-Élysées le jour du 8 mai ça
franchement alors comment vous quelle
analyse vous portez
tous d'accord c'est c'est représentatif
de l'extrême
dégradation de de la société et c'est
vrai qu'on a cette tentation de la
violence qu'on va retrouver plus tard
quand on va parler du maire de
Saint-Brévin mais qui est une
violence qui monte et que l'État
n'arrive pas à endiguer alors que ce
soit la très grande criminalité comme on
le voit à Marseille ou que ce soit la
violence est vraiment en train de
devenir endémique et de gangrener
toute la société ce qui est choquant
dans ce qui est arrivé là et je le
répète la comparaison avec le
Royaume-Uni quand même intéressantes
parce que sous le le couronnement
de Charles III on a bien eu les
opposants il y avait une foule
considérable et les opposants ont pu
arrêter des opposants à rester le matin
les républicains la manifestation
républicaine est arrêtée par la police
et vint opposants sont mis en prison je
veux dire justement pour Charles III il
y a eu la même tentation ce qui est
intéressant si je peux me permettre de
rebondir à ce que vous disiez Nicolas
c'est que on peut on peut mettre en face
à face deux images celle d'Emmanuel
Macron remontant les Champs-Élysées
totalement seuls et les casseroles qui
accueillent Emmanuel Macron à Lyon le 8
mai alors qu'on est censé quand même il
vient faire un discours pour parler de
Jean Moulin pour commémorer la fin de la
guerre de 39-45 et par cet acte ces gens
semblent aussi c'est manifestants
semblent mettre sur le même palier comme
l'a fait Sandrine Rousseau leur
opposition à la réforme des retraites
une commémoration historique qui est
censée rassembler toute la nation et on
pourrait peut-être se dire qu'à ce
moment-là on fait une pause dans la
lutte et peut-être on communique et ça
montre bien en effet comme le disait
Nicolas cette fracture
dans la société alors dans la majorité
quand même une conclusion qui est très
préoccupante pour notre pays qui est
quand même maintenant rentré dans une
phase où il va très mal c'est que
contrairement à ce que dit le président
on ne peut pas réformer sans rassembler
et donc aujourd'hui c'est ça la
contradiction ne veut pas réformer sans
demander l'avis du peuple justement on
va écouter certains dans la majorité qui
sont conscients que l'épisode des
retraites laissera des traces la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
demande une réforme des institutions
écoutez là
moi ce que je souhaiterais à titre
personnel c'est une réforme
institutionnelle qui permette de
garantir une meilleure participation à
nos concitoyens dans la vie politique
donc il faut faciliter l'usage de
référendum en France que ce soit un
référendum d'initiative de l'exécutif ou
un référendum d'initiative citoyenne là
je crois qu'il y a un vrai sujet
cette possibilité cette ouverture du
référendum ce serait une manière aussi
une solution d'une certaine manière à la
crise démocratique qui dit pas son nom
on croit comprendre que c'est on en
prend pas trop le chemin mais ce
référendum je ne fais pas référence à la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel qui
qui
est globalement
de reprise mais ça c'est autre chose je
suis pas du tout dans ce débat là mais
le clairement le référendum d'initiative
populaire on en prend pas le chemin du
d'aucune façon
c'est le serpent de mer on va réformer
les institutions chaque fois que c'est
tendu on dit on transformer mais ça fait
tellement longtemps c'est évidemment
complexe redonner redonner la parole au
peuple c'est aussi par exemple redonner
travailler peut-être sur la façon dont
les débats parlementaires s'organisent
redonner l'ordre du jour au
parlementaire enfin il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui sont qui sont qui
sont possibles mais bon la parole à
Nicolas baverrez sur le référendum ce
serait une manière aussi de de sortir de
la crise et finalement d'apaiser un peu
Emmanuel Macron par beaucoup
d'apaisement jusqu'au 14 juillet je
crois que si vous les la casseroles ça
remonte à Louis-Philippe et Tocqueville
avait fait un très beau discours à
l'Assemblée juste quelques semaines
avant que Louis-Philippe ne soit
renversé pour dire que ce qu'il fallait
changer c'était surtout l'esprit l'état
d'esprit du gouvernement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la même
chose c'est-à-dire que bien sûr on peut
avoir des on peut étendre le référendum
ce qui ne va vraiment pas aujourd'hui
c'est l'esprit du gouvernement et la
manière dont le pouvoir exercer donc le
général de Gaulle c'était un militaire
la stratégie était à l'Élysée l'opératif
à Matignon le tactique dans les
ministères on a tout fait remonter à
l'Elysée pour la moindre chose ça ça ne
peut pas marcher on a une assemblée qui
est transformée en ZAD au lieu de
s'occuper de contrôler le gouvernement
de voter la loi et de débattre dignement
et on a un pouvoir et on a une autorité
judiciaire qui est en guerre ouverte
avec et l'exécutif et le législatif donc
aujourd'hui je pense que il faut avant
tout remettre les institutions en état
de marche en essayant de retrouver un
peu de leur esprit de d'origine et que
ça me paraît plus important même que de
que d'ouvrir davantage le référendum le
Père Noël existe-t-il les amis si oui il
s'appelle peut-être Emmanuel Macron
c'est en tout cas ce que dit certains
économistes au regard des promesses des
dernières semaines depuis son allocution
mi-avril beaucoup de milliards ont été
annoncés à droite à gauche mais le
gouvernement l'assurant encore cette
semaine quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
terminé
je suis totalement déterminé pour ne pas
dire inflexible sur le rétablissement de
nos comptes publics d'ici 2027 et sur
l'attein de nos objectifs baisser la
dette publique de manière accélérée pour
atteindre 100% de dette publique en 2027
et revenir sous les 3% de déficit en
2027 ça va demander un engagement de
tous ça va demander un engagement de la
majorité ça va demander un engagement de
tous les ministres sans exception mais
ça va demander un engagement des
collectivités locales
tout le monde Bruno Le Maire déterminé
mais plusieurs journalistes ont fait le
compte des annonces du gouvernement de
ces dernières semaines je vais vous les
décrire il y a le plan vélo 2 milliards
d'euros sur quatre ans la réforme du
lycée professionnel un milliard d'euros
le plan handicap 1,5 milliards d'euros
l'augmentation du salaire des profs 2 à
3 milliards d'euros l'augmentation des
bourses pour les étudiants 500 millions
d'euros je vous donne la parole Nicolas
et puis après je fais tourner un petit
peu la parole mais c'est plus en même
temps c'est de la schizophrénie donc
d'un côté on a comment on l'a vu une qui
est quand même une demi réforme des
retraites qui se débouchent sur une
crise politique et sociale majeure
de l'autre côté on a des agences de
notation qui dégradent notre pays avec
une dette de 3 milliards d'euros qui
posent des problèmes majeurs maintenant
la France est la dernière en Europe
l'Italie et la Grèce se sont des
endettés pas mal avec l'inflation nous
ça n'est pas le cas et de l'autre côté
on a effectivement un président de la
République qui distribue les milliards
dont on sait pas d'ailleurs vraiment à
quoi il servent s'ils seront vraiment
dépensés donc en tout cas le message il
est dramatique en réalité le quoi qu'il
en coûte le quoi qu'il en coûte il y a
une préférence absolue pour la dépense
et la dette publique et tout ceci va se
terminer très mal avec un pays qui va
aller heurter le mur de
pleine remontée des taux d'intérêt la
question c'est mais si pourquoi
Bérengère est-ce que si je le pose la
question de manière un peu brutale le
gouvernement achète la paix sociale
après cet épisode des retraites
la réponse est dans la question
si je peux me permettre il y a un point
d'interrogation
achète la paix sociale après après
effectivement ce cet épisode des
retraites qui n'en finit plus de se
finir et de ne pas se finir
c'est-à-dire même la réforme elle-même
compte tenu du du fait que l'objectif
était de de d'économiser genre c'est 13
milliards par an je parle sous contrôle
de Nicolas 13 milliards par an et là bon
on a on a fait le calcul c'est 7 8
milliards qui ont été distribués en
quelques semaines mais mais il y a il y
en a déjà quelques-uns qui ont été
distribués dans la réforme elle-même
dans les ajustements ce qui est ce qui
est ce qui est sans doute important mais
je veux dire il y a déjà une partie du
bénéfice de cette réforme qui a été vidé
dans la réforme elle-même et puis
effectivement on continue et dans le
même temps moi j'ai encore entendu Bruno
Le Maire cette semaine
rappeler vous savez la France vous savez
combien la France emprunte chaque année
270 milliards donc chaque année c'est le
premier émetteur de dette de la zone
euro donc il nous rappelle ça il nous
rappelle évidemment et il a raison à
quel point un point de taux d'intérêt
supplémentaire contre
une fortune 15 milliards par an
et dans le même temps
soit c'est de la contorsion quoi parce
que parce que le je pense que le le
l'estomac de Bruno Le Maire il doit
j'espère qu'il fait du yoga ou je ne
sais pas mais parce que c'est compliqué
je veux dire de fait
il donne enfin il donne dans une main et
puis et puis il essaie de reprendre dans
l'autre mais mais on sait pas c'est
politique quoi c'est ce qu'on comprend
azilise j'ai l'impression que c'est
l'essence du macronisme parce que Macron
a toujours gouverné comme ça après les
gilets jaunes il a arrosé
mais ces dernières semaines on est à
Bruno Le Maire qui fait un discours sur
la fraude sociale ensuite on a Gabriel
attaque qui va nous parler des ultra
riches pour lutter contre la fraude
fiscale et donc c'est toujours des
contrefeux permanents qui sont allumés
et là j'ai l'impression que c'est
également le cas et c'est dommage pour
l'unité de la nation justement et c'est
ça qui provoque aussi cette crise
politique et qu'il entretient parce que
les milliards qui sont des bloqués sont
des bloqués quand même pour des projets
intéressants notamment pour pour le
Lycée professionnel
à un moment après la réforme des
retraites et évidemment tout le monde va
se dire c'est pour acheter la paix
sociale c'est un quoi qu'il en coûte qui
ne se termine plus en fait parce que
tous les deux mois on entend à je pense
que c'est des promesses je suis pas sûr
que les milliards vont être débloqués je
pense qu'il y a des effets d'annonces
parce que effectivement comme on l'a dit
le pays est assez crispé assez agité il
y a une opposition forte donc comment
décrisper il faut au moins des effets
d'annonce donc dire qu'on va embaucher
des agents pour faire des contrôles
fiscaux comme l'a fait Attal 1500 postes
on sait pas s'ils vont vraiment être
embauchés à l'arrivée mais bon en tout
cas le dire ça déclenche un espèce
d'effet de dire ah bah il agissent voilà
et pareil promettre quelques millions
ici et là quelques centaines de millions
ici et là ça peut permettre de tasser un
peu le truc on verra bien il y en a un
qui avait fait ça avec une certaine
maestria quand même que Nicolas Sarkozy
qui régulièrement promettait des
milliards pour la sécurité pour la lutte
contre l'immigration pour les lycées
pour la réforme des universités les
fameuses grandes fondations des
universités que Nicolas Sarkozy avait
promise on les a pas vraiment vu donc
voilà c'est c'est une bonne technique de
gouvernement assez classique sous la 5e
République les résultats le résultat
c'est le chiffre qu'on va voir la dette
de la France qui frôle désormais les
3000 milliards d'euros avec un déficit à
4,7% du PIB la France est en faillite
pour reprendre
l'expression d'un certain François
Fillon l'État est en faillite
aujourd'hui et on continue à dépenser
je crois que là encore c'est bien de
regarder ce qui c'est ce qui s'est passé
à l'étranger le Royaume-Uni de listrot a
sauté financièrement en 15 jours et donc
penser que c'est vrai que pour l'instant
les Cassandre n'ont pas été écoutés
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que ce sont des
des Cassandre on a l'impression qu'il ne
s'est rien passé mais le simple coût de
la charge de la dette va tendre vers 70
milliards d'euros ça va devenir quand
même le premier budget de l'État et si
la hausse des taux continue ce qui est
quand même probable elle va ralentir
mais elle va continuer c'est vrai qu'on
va se retrouver avec une dette qui sera
difficilement très très difficilement
soutenable et avec la possibilité
d'avoir un vrai choc financier sur sur
la France et ce qui s'est passé au
Royaume-Uni montre que ce sont pas des
c'est pas des menaces en l'air ça peut
ça peut tout à fait arriver et ce que
vous avez dit est tout à fait juste
c'est à dire que je crois que le slogan
du quoi qu'il en coûte il est vraiment
dramatique
de créer dans la tête des Français que
l'argent public était gratuit et
illimité
pas facilement et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la classe politique
française n'a plus ni les moyens ni la
volonté de reprendre la maîtrise des
comptes publics ce qui est compliqué
c'est que en même temps ce quoi qui en
coûte ça a été quand même ce qui a
permis à la France de s'en tirer
beaucoup mieux que d'autres pendant
cette période du covid puisque c'était
de ça qu'il s'agissait de de tenter de
maintenir à flot des entreprises qui
dans d'autres pays notamment européens
souffraient sans doute beaucoup plus de
fait il faut il faut sans doute se
réjouir malgré tout que la France est
fait ce choix à ce moment là de sortir
de la planche à billets maintenant le
problème c'est qu'il faut il faut
revenir évidemment à sa nécessite après
de resserrer évidemment
c'est une vraie question parce que si on
resserre ça veut dire qu'on resserre la
masse monétaire ça veut dire qu'on
augmente la valeur réelle
non mais faut faire autrement mais
justement le but de l'inflation et donc
de laisser un peu filer c'est qu'elle
ait une baisse relative donc là je
laisse l'économiste nous l'expliquer
mais si on a ni croissance ni inflation
du point de vue de la dette on est
flingué enfin c'est simple non mais bon
d'abord la politique monétaire
c'est c'est la BCE ensuite qu'est-ce
qu'il faut regarder c'est vrai qu'elle
est la situation des finances publiques
en elle-même elle est tout à fait
dégradée et inquiétante ce qui est
intéressant dans le ce que font les
agences et qui s'arrêtent pas là et
c'est d'une certaine manière le plus
inquiétant pour notre pays qui qu'est-ce
qui regarde ensuite il regarde trois
choses la croissance potentielle la
croissance potentielle c'est avant tout
les gains de productivité chez nous ça
baisse depuis sa baisse depuis 2019 donc
effectivement ensuite il regarde la
capacité à avoir un consensus social je
crois qu'on vient d'en parler
abondamment ensuite la capacité des
dirigeants politiques à faire des
réformes et là aussi traditionnellement
la cinquième république est-elle et
aujourd'hui
paralysé entre la majorité relative et
puis la faible légitimité du président
donc c'est ce tableau général
les agences mais aussi les investisseurs
et d'ailleurs nos partenaires européens
et c'est ce tableau général qui
aujourd'hui est inquiétant on en vient à
cette démission qui fait beaucoup réagir
dans la loi Atlantique Yannick Morel
mère de la commune de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins a annoncé sa
démission cette semaine son projet de
transfert d'un centre de réfugiés près
d'une école avait provoquée des
manifestations de riverains et de
groupuscules d'extrême droite sont
domicile avait même été incendiés fin
mars dans un communiqué il pointe du
doigt le manque de soutien de l'État
l'Association des maires de France parle
d'un échec pour la République écoutez
cela fait des années que nous alertons
sur les violences subies par les élus
cela fait des mois que nous alertons sur
les manifestations d'extrême droite
contre les centres d'accueil pour les
demandeurs d'asile et malheureusement
l'état n'a pas été au rendez-vous
démocratique républicain aujourd'hui la
situation est un échec un échec grâce
pour la République je vais vous lire le
communiquer de Yannick Morel j'ai pris
cette décision pour des raisons
personnelles notamment suite à
l'incendie criminel permettrait à mon
domicile et au manque de soutien de
l'État et après une longue réflexion
menée avec ma famille azilise c'est
l'échec de l'État c'est des missions
et du gouvernement ça fait un effet des
années que les élus alertent c'est c'est
absolument terrible ce qui s'est passé
enfin je veux dire là on a mis en danger
des vies on s'est attaqué la propriété
privée d'un homme qui conçoit d'accord
avec son action politique ou non a été
élu démocratiquement et évidemment
l'État a une responsabilité
après je voyais beaucoup de réactions
qui qui expliquait que c'était le fait
de l'extrême droite évidemment là ça a
l'air d'être le cas je crois qu'il y a
deux pôles qui sont aujourd'hui des
menaces en France et à la fois l'extrême
droite en effet mais aussi l'extrême
gauche il faut faire une hiérarchie
entre les événements là on s'attaque
comme je l'ai dit à une propriété privée
à une personne individu mais l'extrême
gauche dans la rue aussi quand elle
brûle des poubelles quand elles
s'attaque aux institutions
s'attaque à la maison commune finalement
donc elle brûle cette maison qui est la
nôtre donc il y a une violence dans la
société qui est terrible et qui
se dirige en premier vers ceux qui
représentent l'état aujourd'hui et c'est
entre nous par tout ce qu'on a dit avant
justement par cette crise politique et
puis cette crise passion qu'il y a et
l'impression de ne pas être entendu par
le pouvoir non plus il y a une
responsabilité notamment du ministre de
l'Intérieur dans cette histoire Fabrice
je trouve que le problème enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a un problème il y
a deux problèmes globaux il y a celui de
la violence noisy disent parler mais il
y a un deuxième problème qui est
le ras-le-bol des citoyens dans tout ce
qui concerne les dynamiques de
l'engagement si on regarde le
recrutement de la police le recrutement
de la gendarmerie on a de plus en plus
de mal à avoir des candidats pareil chez
les pompiers si on regarde la sécurité
civile des bénévoles beaucoup de
difficultés à recruter au fond tout le
pôle de l'engagement français ce qui
faisait que les gens avaient envie d'y
aller et aujourd'hui en panne pourquoi
ben justement parce que les interactions
avec avec nos concitoyens deviennent de
plus en plus problématiques et et qu'on
est encore moins valorisé quand on
décide de se dévouer comme un élu local
qui paye beaucoup de sa personne en
termes d'heures en termes d'action et
qu'on se retrouve régulièrement avec les
engueulades par les les
électeurs qui disent là il y a telle
poubelle qui reste
des petites incivilités on est en plus
agressé très rapidement physiquement sur
les permis de construire etc et ça fait
un moment que ça monte les Niels c'est
l'Association des maires de France
l'association des maires de France dit
que ça n'arrête pas de monter je crois
que c'est pour ça l'an dernier alors
voilà la violence physique ou verbale
contre les élus augmenter de 32 % en
1293 mères ont démissionné depuis leur
élection en 2020 et le maire de Cannes
Linard demande qu'on fasse une vraie
enquête parce que ils pensent que ces
chiffres sont sous-évalués donc on est
dans un état où tout le monde de
l'engagement est en train d'être épuisé
et je crois pas que c'est l'État qui
peut par sa seule action compenser ça il
y a un truc beaucoup plus profond
Bérengère
je pense moi j'ai du mal à dire
effectivement l'État est responsable de
ça évidemment c'est c'est terrible ce
qui est arrivé à ce monsieur à sa
famille et et ça pose vraiment beaucoup
de questions sur sur la sur la capacité
des élus à avancer de différents projets
mais c'est assez transversal et attends
ça a été très politisé pour le coup ces
derniers jours et attention parce que il
y a une enquête encore qui n'a pas rendu
ses conclusions
c'est très difficile et sans nous c'est
une enquête de terrain qui pourrait le
dire mais j'avais commandé j'avais
demandé des patrouilles autour de chez
lui pour protéger ce cet homme
évidemment c'est difficile de savoir si
ça a été réellement le cas mais en
revanche effectivement le le les
inquiétudes des élus c'est quelque chose
qui monte depuis longtemps parlez-en à
tous ceux qui constituent des listes
dans les différents partis sur tous les
derniers scrutins je veux dire
honnêtement il commence à y avoir
vraiment des difficultés parfois à
trouver des candidats des candidats à
mettre sur les disques
juste pour revenir parce que ça coupe le
tout ça parce qu'on a un groupe
d'hystérique dans cette dans notre
société
radicaux d'extrême droite radicaux
d'extrême gauche qui n'arrête pas en
fait de d'aller plus loin dans la
pollution de la vie publique
même le dire et peut-être que plus la
mer là c'est pour le coup alors c'est un
terme très vague mais c'est pour le coup
des gens d'extrême droite dans d'autres
municipalités ça va être des militants
d'extrême gauche qui vont mettre en
cause le fonctionnement donc il faut le
dire quand même il y a des radicalisés
qui font mal
largement il y a une désacralisation
aussi de toutes les institutions et de
et de simples principes de hiérarchie
aujourd'hui on a l'impression
par exemple les professeurs sont autant
attaqués violentés etc par leur propre
élève et c'est l'autorité qui est
vraiment ce sentiment et c'est pour à
peu près tous les corps de la société
aujourd'hui vous expliquer ça aussi
comme ça cette montée des violences
Nicolas alors elle s'explique pour pour
beaucoup de raisons parce que c'est la
traduction de la crise du pays il y a
d'abord une paupérisation qui est réelle
des Français ensuite il y a une crise
profonde des classes moyennes et puis il
y a une crise aujourd'hui intellectuelle
morale un vrai doute sur les
institutions sur les valeurs de la
réponse
et les tensions et ça ça a créé le et
par ailleurs en face parce que il y a
quand même la danse aussi une vraie
responsabilité de l'étape puisque je
rappelle quand même que ce centre c'est
l'État qui a décidé de le transférer
c'est pas la décision du maire et c'est
l'État qui répartit ses centres en
France les centres d'accueil de
demandeurs c'est une responsabilité de
l'État dans la localisation de ce centre
est théoriquement enfin le moins qu'on
puisse faire c'est que l'État devrait à
minima garantir la sécurité la sécurité
derrière mais c'est effectivement cette
contagion de la violence c'est vraiment
la violence c'est vraiment l'arme de
destruction massive de la démocratie
donc ce qu'on a laissé s'installer et
prospérer à l'extrême gauche comme à
l'extrême droite c'est tout à fait vrai
mais avec d'ailleurs deux logiques qui
sont des logiques
identitaires derrière c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est extrêmement
dangereux et qui sera difficile qui sera
difficile qui sera difficile à endiguer
donc il faut qu'il y ait il faut qu'il y
ait un vrai sursaut républicain dans
notre pays et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
on ne le on ne le voit pas venir mais
il va dégrader encore notre note les
tailles quand même très important parce
que l'État est quand même dans la l'État
et dans la tête des Français et c'est
vrai que l'espèce d'incroyable tolérance
qu'on a eu pour la violence quand même
depuis des années on a laissé des gens
dans les deux camps faire des en toute
impunité
des choses précisément précisément la
gauche elle pointe du doigt le rôle de
l'extrême droite dans la démission du
maire un hommage a été rendu à
l'Assemblée nationale par le député
socialiste Jérôme Guedj lors de
l'hommage tous les élus se sont levés à
l'exception des députés RN regardez
Yannick Le Maire
missile a été incendié parce qu'il
défendait l'installation d'un centre
d'accueil et de demandeurs d'asile et
donc des événements de cette nature
nous interpelle
[Applaudissements]
il y a une complaisance aujourd'hui avec
l'extrême droite on a vu les
manifestations à Paris le week-end
dernier il y a d'autres cas qui ont été
signalés de pression comme ça sur le sur
les élus je dirais pas je dirais pas
quand même ça parce que Younes c'est
expliqué sur les logiques de du droit
public aussi Nunes de préfet de Paris
c'est à dire que partir du moment où il
y a une manifestation qui s'est déjà
dirigé plusieurs fois déroulés plusieurs
fois dans laquelle il y a pas eu de
violence bon ben il est manifestations
du 9 mai autorisées avec des néonazis
des signes en Asie dans les rues de
Paris exactement donc trouver les
fondements juridiques pour l'interdire
parce que on est quand même dans un état
de droit malgré tout c'est pas toujours
évident et d'ailleurs ce sur quoi il a
pu agir ensuite c'est sûr dissimulation
de visage etc donc c'est sur des des
aspects j'allais dire presque marginaux
par rapport au problème par ailleurs on
peut se poser la question parce que si
on commence à interdire systématiquement
toutes les manifestations je veux dire
on va se retrouver à avoir un autre
débat dans ce plateau en disant que la
démocratie qui sera proche de ce que
disait Bérengère bon tout à l'heure en
disant oui on a peur du peuple on
interdit les manifestations etc donc
malgré tout ils essayent de laisser
fonctionner le système et puis il y a
quand même ce truc c'est l'extrême
droite qu'est-ce qu'elle sera droite là
il faut le dire là c'est les pures
fascistes c'est les pures fascistes
c'est des gens qui font l'équivalent du
salut fasciste qui se retrouve ensuite
pour chanter des hymnes nostalgie à la
suprématie blanche etc donc je veux dire
là on a vraiment parce que faudrait pas
confondre quoi quand on dit extrême
droite on dit extrême droite pour Marine
Le Pen on dit extrême droite pour pour
d'autres comme comme Zemmour là c'est
vraiment c'est pas c'est pas d'extrême
droite c'est du pur fasciste et ce qui a
de dingue c'est qu'aujourd'hui à force
de traiter tout le monde de fasciste
parce qu'il faut quand même le dire en
France on dit que Mélenchon et fasciste
on dit qu'Emmanuel Macron et fasciste on
dit que Marine Le Pen est fasciste et
ben quand on est face à des vrais
fascistes et bon on dit pas on le dit
pas moi c'est ça qui me paraît le plus
sidérant
je vois cette cette problématique si on
dézoome un tout petit peu
j'observe l'ensemble du du premier
quinquennat depuis le début du premier
quinquennat la façon dont Emmanuel
Macron porte pour moi une responsabilité
importante dans la façon qu'il a eu
d'installer l'extrême droite comme son
principal adversaire et sincèrement
encore encore avant Noël quand il agite
la menace d'une dissolution
et il s'est pertinemment que que ça
ouvre un vrai risque de d'accès du
rassemblement national au pouvoir je
veux dire là honnêtement depuis le début
et on l'a maintint maintes fois souligné
mais qu'il a une il a une part de
responsabilité dans le look alors dans
le climat de violence ou avec le feu
franchement depuis le début du
quinquennat là-dessus ce type de groupe
sérieux on est bien d'accord mais j'ai
choisi Marine Le Pen on peut le penser
mais c'est de ça que je parle bien sûr
c'est plus globalement d'accord mais
c'est plus globalement
la montée tolérance
gère si je me trompe pas
est-ce qu'on est plutôt les rang avec
l'extrême droite qu'avec certains
mouvements de gauche de manière générale
non
pas du tout absolument pas et en fait je
crois qu'il y a quelque chose de très
sain si il faut être un peu positif pour
une fois sur le plateau là depuis le
début de l'émission c'est que tout le
monde a été choqué par ces images il y
avait 500 salt types dans la rue
cagoulés
je pense dans l'opinion tout le monde
était choqué de voir ça et ça montre que
la démocratie fonctionne encore un petit
peu puisque on arrive à
sans intervention de l'État sans qu'on
interdise simplement avoir une réaction
des Français et de la classe politique
etc unanimement qui se dit choquée de
cela et qui ne souhaite pas avoir ça
dans les rues donc on a peut-être pas
besoin de toujours faire intervenir la
justice pour interdire la démocratie
fonctionne à peu près correctement
encore
et donc elles sont condamnées après coup
et c'est c'est je ne souhaite pas avoir
des néonazis tous les week-ends dans les
rues de Paris mais bon
en tout cas il faut faire une grosse
différence je crois et ne pas faire de
glissement entre ce qu'on a pu voir dans
ces manifestations et le rassemblement
national je vois pas du tout de lien
entre les deux Marine Le Pen n'a jamais
eu de position néonazi il faut quand
même être honnête et les positions que
peu défendre ce parti sur l'immigrations
même si elles sont radicales à certains
égards
aucun rapport avec ce qui s'est passé et
l'intervention de Jérôme Guedj et de ce
point de vue quand même vraiment une
petite
opération politicienne et qui visait à
mettre mal à l'aise les députés du
rassemblement national oui mais c'est
malhonnête il pouvait pas se lever
puisqu'il y avait un ils étaient
assimilés on les traitent on dit que
c'est le parti d'extrême droite et on
les assimile à ce qui s'est passé je
veux dire la maison brûlée ça n'a quand
même rien à voir c'est dangereux de
faire ça c'est dangereux justement pour
la crise politique qui se passe en
France parce que les électeurs qui
votent pour le rassemblement national
ils sont quand même nombreux et ils sont
encore une fois méprisés
radicaux appelant clairement à une
raciale en revanche l'installation m'a
vraiment je considère que l'installation
dans le débat public de de ce
face-à-face et et vraiment problématique
mais il est problématique
suivant les amis Vladimir Poutine guerre
de civilisation en Ukraine en tout cas
le sens du discours qu'il a prononcé
cette semaine à l'occasion des
commémorations de la victoire de l'URSS
sur l'Allemagne nazie il a dénoncé la
guerre lancé contre son pays écoutez
la civilisation est de nouveau à un
tournant une guerre a été lancée contre
notre patrie mais nous avons lutté
contre le terrorisme international nous
protégerons également le peuple du
don-basse nous assurons notre propre
sécurité
est-il en train de mener une guerre de
civilisation en Ukraine alors en tout
cas c'est ce lui explique que c'est un
mensonge inouï un renversement
incroyable parce que lui explique que
c'est entre guillemets l'Occident global
qui mène une guerre de civilisation
contre contre la Russie il va de soi que
ça n'a rien à voir avec la réalité et la
réalité c'est que
la Russie de Vladimir Poutine a
déclenché une invasion de l'Ukraine qui
débouche sur un conflit de haute
intensité comme on en avait pas connu
depuis 1945 avec des pertes matérielles
et surtout humaines absolument inouï 200
000 et sans doute un peu plus côté russe
largement au-dessus des 200 000 morts et
blessés aussi côté ukrainien c'est aussi
une guerre hybride qui est menée contre
l'Europe avec la transformation du gaz
de l'alimentation
des flux de migrants de des informations
des cyberattaques
tout ceci est mobilisé contre l'Europe
plus les menaces nucléaires nucléaires
et donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a
cette structure évidemment que les
démocraties n'ont pas du tout voulu et
c'est un peu comme dans les années 30
c'est à dire qu'il suffit il ne suffit
pas de d'être pacifiques et de ne pas
vouloir avoir d'ennemis pour ne pas en
avoir en l'occurrence on a maintenant
effectivement une structure là aussi un
monde qui a basculé au cours cette année
2022 avec un affrontement entre les
démocraties les empires autorités et
derrière avec un fort soutien de tout ce
qui est autocrate dans le monde
ça c'est blog contre bloc c'est pas un
axe comme entre la Chine et la Russie ça
ressemble quand même de plus en plus à
une alliance militaire y compris avec
les manœuvres
et des soutiens
divers de pièces détachées d'armement ou
et puis derrière on a cette espèce de
d'international des autocrates qu'on a
vu à Samarcande avec l'organisation de
Shanghai où on trouve effectivement race
et père de Gan on va voir ce que donner
l'élection en Turquie on trouve les
mollets iraniens on trouve MBS en Arabie
Saoudite
on trouve des dirigeants de d'Asie
centrale et donc on a cette espèce
d'international des des régimes
autorités il y a un grand enjeu parce
que c'est pas la répétition de la
première guerre froide il y a un acteur
qui est un acteur très singulier qui est
le sud et on voit que le sud est quand
même tenté de s'aligner ce qu'on a vu
avec la visite de Lula ou la Chine joue
sur le ressentiment
anti colonial et antioxydantal pour
essayer de contourner l'Occident avec ce
paradoxe que la Chine et la Russie
finalement légitime l'impérialisme et le
colonialisme au 21e siècle à partir de
la dénonciation d'ailleurs fondée de
l'IMP colonialisme au 19e siècle Fabrice
vous êtes d'accord ce long exposé de
Nicolas merci beaucoup c'était très
instructif mais vous êtes d'accord sur
cette idée de de blog contre blog vous
avez pas dit ça mais cette idée de
démocratie menacée par les autocraties
et de d'affrontement en tout cas depuis
2007 petit Poutine a une logique il
avait exposé à Munich il y avait une
grande conférence internationale sur la
paix il avait dit en gros son sa vision
du monde et c'est celle que vient de
décrire Nicolas qui est en gros peut se
résumer de manière simple auparavant la
guerre froide c'était Est-Ouest
maintenant ce qu'il prétendent être
c'est le sud c'est à dire que l'est
prétend être le porte-parole du Sud et
ce qui se passe c'est l'Ouest global
contre le sud global et l'Ukraine étant
le point d'affrontement selon Poutine
selon Poutine de ces deux logiques
puisque les États-Unis et l'Europe
soutiennent l'Ukraine tandis que
derrière la Russie se trouverait tout le
sud global et ce qui est un peu triste
c'est que c'est peut-être pas
complètement faux parce que dans un des
terrains qui vous intéresse beaucoup
l'Afrique on s'aperçoit que l'opinion
publique africaine est beaucoup de chefs
d'État africains ont vis-à-vis de la
Russie plutôt de la sympathie et quand
on change et qu'on va regarder d'autres
pays qui qui sont pas forcément
directement impliqués et dont Nicolas il
y en a un qui l'a oublié Nicolas dans
son exposé c'est l'Inde
l'Inde au départ est pro ukrainienne les
médias indiens sont procréiens et on
voit progressivement les voies prorus
commencent à prendre une place et on
voit que le positionnement du pays d'une
neutralité devient un petit peu plus
ambigu donc effectivement ce qui se
dessine aux positions ouest Sud c'est
c'est une tension montante
aussi en France c'est que Vladimir
Poutine bénéficie quand même d'un
certain soutien au sein de la société
russe je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions de la population des réactions
célébrations du 9 mai à écouter
un sentiment de fierté a toujours surgi
pendant la parade et surgit encore
aujourd'hui mais maintenant il y a une
nouvelle émotion et une fois en la
victoire nous espérons et croyons tous
qu'il y aura une victoire
que nos grands-pères nos grands-mères
c'est à dire que nous sommes maintenant
contraints de nous défendre à nouveau
contre le néonazisme ressuscité
nous nous rappelons nous sommes fiers et
nous ne pouvons pas l'oublier parce que
maintenant les pays de l'Union
européenne sont en train de réécrire
l'histoire et ça c'est inacceptable la
peste fasciste refait surface mais nous
devons libérer les pays d'Europe le
monde entier de cette peste fasciste
azilise on a un peu de mal à comprendre
ce soutien de la population pour
Vladimir Poutine une experte de la
question mais ce que je trouve
intéressant dans ce que je peux entendre
c'est que depuis l'annexion de la Crimée
en 2014 Poutine a un discours en effet
de guerre sainte où il semble être une
grande guerre contre cet Occident
décadents et c'est une question
peut-être que je peux en fait poser à
Nicolas par extension mais quand on
regarde ce qui se passe en Russie
notamment sur la question de
l'avortement qui revient souvent dans le
discours de Poutine il y a 480
avortements pour 1000 naissance moi
j'étais Héber lui et de constater ça en
France et 15 pour 1000 et donc et aux
États-Unis c'est 200 pour 1000 enfin
voilà en Russie il y a vraiment un
chiffre spectaculaire alors qu'ils
Vladimir Poutine semble dire que c'est
nous qui sommes qui sommes décadence
notamment sur ces questions là alors
qu'en est-il réellement en fait dans la
population russe est-ce que les Russes
sont satisfaits de l'action de Vladimir
Poutine et est-ce que finalement cette
guerre sainte n'est pas ce qui lui
permet lui aussi de s'asseoir et de
tenir
son siège de prison
très rapidement pour aller très vite sur
l'opinion russe ce qui est vrai c'est
que bon la Russie est immense et qui a
toute une ça dépend des générations et
que ça dépend aussi de entre les villes
ou les grandes villes et puis les
campagnes les choses sont très
différentes mais ce qui est certain
c'est que compte tenu de la dégradation
de l'économie russe compte tenu aussi du
du renforcement de la de l'État policier
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il y a quand même
de plus en plus en tout cas de gens qui
peuvent croire à la propagande mais qui
sont néanmoins de plus en plus réservés
devant cette guerre et j'allais dire il
y a quand même un fait avéré c'est qu'il
y a un million de jeunes Russes qui ont
voté avec leurs pieds en quittant le
pays pour éviter non seulement pour
éviter la mobilisation mais aussi pour
pouvoir poursuivre une une vie et en
tout cas ne pas dépendre de Vladimir
Poutine existe-t-il une cancelle culture
de droite c'est notre dernier thème une
œuvre de l'artiste Myriam Kahn exposé au
Palais de Tokyo à Paris a été vandalisé
par un ancien élu du Front national le
tableau qu'on va voir est exposé depuis
mi-février et suscite les critiques de
plusieurs associations qui est le jugent
qui ce tableau représente un enfant
subissant un viol l'artiste dit quand
elle qu'il s'agit d'une manière de
dénoncer les horreurs de la guerre en
Ukraine la ministre de la Culture a pris
sa défense écouter qu'est-ce qu'a fait
le rassemblement national une députée
venue filmer ce tableau mettre l'oeuvre
sortie de son contexte sur les réseaux
sociaux et elle vous a directement
interpellé à l'Assemblée à continuer à
relayer ça sur les réseaux sociaux oui
c'est de l'instrumentalisation et c'est
de la déformation donc là on est
complètement dans une une dérive de
censure c'est très clairement de la
censure de la part du rassemblement
national et de tous ceux qui ont tenté
de faire décrocher cette Bérengère vous
voyez de l'Ascension aussi de la part de
certains élus non je suis heureuse
d'entendre une mise au gouvernement
parler de libertés d'expression
c'est dit voilà alors
censure de faire attention aux grands
mots quoi mais mais
il y a une œuvre qui enfin globalement
la cancer culture est quand même quelque
chose qui qui moi me posent toujours
soucis ça veut pas dire que oui la
liberté d'expression c'est la liberté
d'expression enfin ça ne transige pas
avec ça en fait juste pour définir ce
que c'est que quand cette culture c'est
la culture de l'annulation ça va être
dénoncer publiquement des oeuvres pour
les sortir de l'espace public et on en
vient à ce duels oui on va faire un duel
on va faire
on va faire un duel avec cette question
existe-t-il une cancer culture de droite
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de conseils
culture de gauche mais existe-t-il une
concept culture de droite deux invités
sur ce plateau ne sont pas d'accord le
Cher Fabrice n'est pas d'accord avec
Azilis 45 secondes chacun et azilise
vous allez nous dire pourquoi selon vous
oui en 40 secondes il existe une
cancelle culture de droite alors il
existe non seulement une cantine culture
de droite mais une bien-pensance de
droite comme il existe une bien-pensance
de gauche pourquoi parce que la droite à
un moment donné a arrêté de penser
puisque pendant des années on a une
domination
médiatique de la bien-pensance de gauche
et par réaction la droite en tout cas
une partie de la droite c'est construite
pour répondre à cette domination là et à
gauche enfin c'est la gauche faut que
qui qui procède à cette cancelle culture
le dominant c'est cet oxydant mortifère
etc à droite c'est cette gauche qui a
dominé donc chacun son dominant et on
arrête de penser on arrête de proposer
des choses politiques pour le bien vivre
dans le but de trouver un consensus et
discuter mais on se construit en
réaction c'est vraiment en contre et
c'est ça qui crée la bien pour sens de
droite et la grande salle culture de
droite non non parce que c'est pas du
tout équivalent il se trouve que la
gauche se nourrit de l'idée quel est le
parti du bien le parti où tout ce qui
est pensé est juste est incontestable et
à partir de ce moment là à partir de
cette vérité la gauche a défini la
cancelle culture c'est-à-dire la
possibilité de ne plus parler d'une
personne qui ne correspond pas justement
à la vérité et au bien en revanche à
droite on passe son temps à penser qu'on
a une vertu morale supérieure à celle de
la gauche et donc on veut en permanence
faire honte à la gauche des mauvaises
attitudes et des mauvais comportements
qu'elle a si bien que la droite passe
son temps à dénoncer la moindre petite
attitude de gauche qui n'est pas
conforme à son sens de la vertu dernier
exemple en date on s'attaque au trans
qui vont faire du sport féminin pour en
faire un exemple absolu alors que c'est
absolument marginal vous l'avez fâché
la députée rennes du Pas-de-Calais
Caroline Parmentier qui avait interpellé
le gouvernement fin mars au sujet de
cette justement
en tant que membre de de la commission
des affaires culturelles en tant que
membre de la délégation au droit des
enfants mais surtout en tant que femme
et en tant que mère je vous demande
madame la ministre si l'exposition de ce
genre de tableau sera l'un des marqueurs
de votre mandat un glissement vers la
démocratisation et l'acceptation de ce
type d'oeuvre et si ce n'est pas le cas
je vous le demande solennellement quand
ce tableau va-t-il être décroché à
l'économiste l'avocat Nicolas qu'est-ce
que vous inspire ces propos je vais vous
poser la question encore brutalement
elle existe-t-il une Consulting quand
celle culture de droite
on l'a dit
premièrement il faut évidemment qu'il y
ait une liberté d'expression dans les
démocraties et ça s'applique aux œuvres
d'art personne n'est obligé d'aller
avoir une exposition avec et quand on va
on peut être on peut être heurté par des
œuvres d'art et néanmoins les respecter
deuxièmement c'est là encore
on aura quand même beaucoup parlé de de
ce problème dans cette émission mais à
juste titre c'est cette intolérance qui
se répand et surtout le passage à l'acte
avec la violence parce que les tableaux
sont aussi saccagés par les économistes
les écologistes radicaux
des fleuves de Van Gogh donc cette
espèce de manière à la fois d'acheter sa
minute de célébrité et puis de tout en
tout en saccageant une oeuvre d'art
c'est vrai que cette cette insupportable
et on en est toujours à cette espèce de
maintenant de de blocage communautaire
ou de radicalité et d'intolérance il
faut jamais oublier qu'une démocratie
c'est le suffrage universel c'est l'état
de droit mais c'est aussi le fait qu'on
accepte que on peut avoir des gens
différents que la minorité accepte qu'il
y a une majorité que cette majorité
gouverne et que la majorité ne prime pas
la
minorité et c'est vraiment ça qui est en
train de se perdre
beau milieu d'une guerre culturelle on
pourrait dire ça comme ça alors première
juste sur le tableau il faut quand même
préciser que c'est pas un tableau
pédophriminel quand on moi j'étais à
l'exposition quand on regarde il y a un
petit encart et après on peut trouver ça
lait enfin je ne vends pas des diestique
sur ce tableau mais il y a bien écrit
que c'est pour dénoncer les horaires de
la garde on en pense ce qu'on veut ce
n'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'il y a
des sortes de bulles d'opinion où on ne
parle qu'à ceux qui pensent comme nous
les médias ont la responsabilité
là-dessus pas seulement le service
public parce qu'on accuse toujours le
service public peut-être a-t-il été le
premier à en partie
créer cette bien-pensance de gauche dont
on parlait il y a d'autres médias qui le
font avec d'autres points de vue
politique aujourd'hui et les réseaux
sociaux qui sont les nouveaux médias ne
parlent en effet qu'à des bulles TikTok
twitch aujourd'hui tous les émissions
qui peuvent exister s'adressent à des
gens qui pensent déjà qui sont déjà
acquis à une cause et donc chacun reste
aujourd'hui dans sa famille politique et
n'en sort sera radicalise dans ses
opinions et ça participe on fait la
boucle avec le début de l'émission à
cette crise qui est à la fois politique
et démocratique et surtout pas ça l'acte
et c'est ça qui est inacceptable
Bérengère là-dessus sur cette lutte
entre plusieurs radicalités
de bulles d'opinion qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire je parlais de bataille
culturelles comment vous définir comment
définir cette ce phénomène auquel on
assiste aujourd'hui moi je ça me fait
penser à ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
depuis le début de la mandature et quand
on voit
le groupe et les filles qui hurle
pendant qui pendant qu'une première
ministre s'exprime je veux dire on est
dans un niveau
à peu près tous les groupes on pourrait
on pourrait pour le coup il y a des
moments qui sont quand même pas pas très
glorieux dans cette assemblée et et
c'est un vrai voilà c'est un vrai souci
quand même quand on parle d'exemplarité
suspendu merci président marcher comme
chaque semaine on termine l'émission par
un top flop je vous pose une question
très simple qui a marqué l'actualité de
la semaine en bien ou en match chers
Fabrice vous commencez votre top qui
sert à mon top mon top c'était le
week-end dernier 3 jours de festivités
qui a évoqué très rapidement en Nicolas
tout à l'heure en Grande-Bretagne autour
de Charles et de Camille et je dois
avouer que si je les trouve au top c'est
qu'il faut imaginer Peter et Gladys
c'était les surnoms qui s'étaient donné
vous savez dans les conversations
clandestine qu'ils avaient à la fin des
années 70 au début des années 80 qui
étaient dans leur dans leur petit dans
leur petite bulles justement amoureuse
et qui deviennent finalement les
souverains de ce pays et dans la
cérémonie il y a un moment qui m'a
sidéré c'est Camilla avec sa couronne
sur la tête qui s'avance vers lui pour
ça Genouillé et à ce moment-là un
sourire et on se dit tiens il partage
quelque chose derrière votre flop très
rapidement en 5 secondes Trump Trump qui
pense revenir
et qui malgré tout a fait une émission
derrière
donc voilà à suivre Bérengère votre top
le top alors c'est c'est Bruno Le Maire
qui alors on revient sur le dernier
sujet centraux de cette émission mais
qui est interrogé cette semaine sur
l'interdiction de certains passages par
la première ministre de mon livre pardon
de revenir mais voilà c'est c'est un
vrai sujet sur la liberté d'expression
on lui demande on lui expose ce sujet et
il dit rien n'est plus précieux que la
liberté celle d'écrire celle de publier
et c'est d'autant plus important à un
moment où les pouvoirs autoritaires sont
en train de reprendre du poil de la bête
en 5 secondes mon flop cette boutique
éphémère Shane qui a été ouverte à Paris
ce qui me désole en plus c'est que vous
regardez dans la file d'attente il y a
une moyenne d'âge qui est très très
basse avec des gens alors avec un
conflit entre un problème de pouvoir
d'achat réel c'est des freins qui sont
pas chers mais qui sont un symbole de
surconsommation de fabrication dans des
conditions abominables environnementales
sociales et Nicolas même question top
flop en 15 secondes s'il vous plaît
alors ambiguïté de la politique
internationale donc d'abord le discours
de Scholtz c'est un TOP pour l'Allemagne
avec la vision d'une grande Europe à 38
qui serait dominée par l'Allemagne parce
qu'elle peut avoir une majorité si
chaque pays vote évidemment c'est un
flop pour la France qui n'a même pas été
mentionné dans le discours là aussi le
retour d'Assad dans le flop dans la
Ligue arabe
c'est évidemment pour lui c'est un TOP
puisque c'est la victoire pour lui pour
le reste du monde et notamment surtout
pour l'Occident et pour les ce qui avait
été le printemps arabe c'est un flop
terrible et les historiens verront à
quel point ce printemps arabe de 2011 et
son échec ont joué un rôle absolument de
bascule extrêmement important dans dans
le début du XXe votre top de la semaine
alors mon top c'est un hommage à Thierry
Courtin qui est le papa de T'choupi
T'choupi c'est ce manchot
[Applaudissements]
plupart des livres pour enfants qui a un
peu plus de 30 ans et voilà moi mon fils
aîné on est fan et donc hier j'étais
très triste de lui
était parti et mon flop c'est
l'interdiction des ventes des piscines
hors-sol dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
qui va peut-être se généraliser je ne
l'espère pas parce que je pense que il y
a des choses très importantes à mettre
en oeuvre contre la sécheresse mais que
ça stigmatise encore une fois les plus
pauvres qui n'ont pas les moyens d'avoir
des piles creusées et en plus ça rend
l'écologie punitive et il ne faut
surtout pas couper la population de ces
enjeux cruciaux c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à tous les cas d'avoir
répondu présent ça lui avoue derrière
votre écran me dit dans l'oreillette que
vous êtes des mille et des centres en
tout cas de plus en plus nombreux à nous
suivre vous pouvez nous retrouver cette
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre nouvelle plateforme
public sénat.fr on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même jour même heure
et même endroit